[music]
>> Hey, um I'm Sally. I work at Red Hat.
I've been there for about 10 years and
uh the first 7 years, awesome, totally
cool. I was working on containers and uh
Linux security stuff and Kubernetes. Um
in OpenShift. That's what I did for the
first 7 years.
And then uh about 3 years ago, well
about 5 years ago, I moved to the
emerging tech org and that was awesome,
too, because now I'm not totally tied to
a product. I get to just work on what I
want. I get to just try out new things.
Awesome. And then about 3 years ago it
was like all AI all the time, everything
AI. I know not I knew there was a data
science team at Red Hat. I had no idea
what they did. Machine learning
something something. Um so, I, you know,
started doing AI and uh
yeah, it was a lot of Python and
markdown. Every single thing was like,
"Okay, another chatbot, more Python,
more markdown." Um but uh here we are
today and what a what a crazy awesome
world we're in. Um so, the first time
the first time I came across OpenClaw, I
was home for a week on a like a
staycation, took a few days off and uh
a malt book happened and I was like,
"What the
What is this? I'm totally trying this."
And so, I went and found it on GitHub.
The first thing I do is I look at the
license. Uh MIT, awesome. Uh OpenClaw,
I'm like, "I'm so going to install this
on OpenShift right now." And so, for the
next few days I just kind of built the
image, um
ran it locally in a container, put it on
OpenShift, just played around with it.
Went back to work and like, "Guys,
check out OpenClaw. This is so cool."
And a couple people on Slack are like,
"It's a security nightmare. Do not use
OpenClaw. Don't put it on the work
laptop."
I'm like, "Guys,
what have I What have I been doing the
past 10 years? Is I'm We're We can take
any application and run it securely.
Like that's what rel is. Like if we
can't take an application and run it
securely, like come on. This is our
golden opportunity to show everyone."
And so, Red Hat's coming around to that.
Um but
yeah, so uh this talk is about me
running in containers. And so, I wanted
to get a list of uh So,
I wanted to get a list of why running in
containers is the way to go. I run
everything in containers. I It's kind of
foreign to me to take to just run
something natively. It's messy. It just
puts stuff on my computer that I have to
clean up later. I don't like it. Um so,
that's one one one thing. Uh and I um
ask my forever claw.
I guess I have to introduce my forever
claw cuz she she's she's she's coming
through this whole talk, so I'm going to
aside. My forever claw is Shubra and um
she I have two sub agents. I have Joy.
Uh anyone know
Jyotish astrology?
Jeez, every time I ask, no one knows
what it is. It's
very scientific astrology. Um so, she's
an astrology expert and she gives me my
weekly readings, my birth chart, all of
that. So, Joy and then my second agent
is Bruno and he gives me daily briefings
on the Bruins.
Um
so, we're heading into the playoffs and
it's a close race, so I want to make
sure the Bruins get in.
Um so, that's my forever claw and uh
and I asked her, you know, why should we
run you in container? And uh she said
all of that if you were reading, but
it's reproducible, you can isolate your
secrets, it's portable across infra, I
can run on my laptop, I can run it on my
X86, I can run it on my Mac, I can run
it in Kubernetes. Um backed by volumes,
which gives a really nice story for
backup and recovery. Uh cuz I love my
forever claw and I I back her up every
night with uh with uh
um like a system D service, whatever
it's called on Mac. And um and and you
just get that natural uh
you just get that natural sandbox when
you run something in a container. It's
it's, you know, that's that's what it is
and you have to be very explicit about
what you um give access to, you know,
from the host. And so, this Yes, I she
loves running in a container. So, that's
that's all you need to know. Um it gives
her a clean, predictable environment,
doesn't have to worry about the OS
quirks, stale dependencies. This is
literally the definition of why you
should run everything in containers.
And uh
just quickly, we're not going to read
this, but this is Joy, my horoscope. Um
it's for today for giving a talk is
excellent. It's like a very auspicious
day to talk. Uh so, yeah. That's why
this talk is going awesome so far.
And uh
my daily briefing, uh Geeky, is finally
waking up. He had a bit of a lull. He's
finally
you know, ramping up for the playoffs,
so it looks like the Bruins are going to
be looking good. They're in and uh
yeah.
So,
yeah, so um
containers, it allows me to
Uh another another thing that containers
do is you can set up a whole agent
directory with maybe you run some tools,
some skills, some MCP servers. Uh you
can
keep those in a directory and mount that
whole thing into your container
uh and
so, when at startup everything's just up
and running.
So, I do that as well.
At the end of this talk, I'll show you
how I install and I think this is a
reminder to me Oh, no, let's talk about
secrets.
So, I run everything with Podman, not
Docker. Um but
in theory you can do anything with
Podman and Docker. Except, Podman has
this really cool feature called Podman
secrets. And you can save your API keys.
I'll show that I'll I'll show it off the
sides later. You can save your API keys
to a Podman secret.
And then you mount that secret into the
container. And so, it just gives the
separation. Your your secrets, your API
keys are then just a ref back to the
secret. And with OpenClaw, what's really
cool is there's like a double that
because in OpenClaw there's a secret ref
feature and I also use that. So, my API
keys are
pointer to a secret ref to the outside
secret. And uh that's not perfect, but
it gives me some peace of mind that I
don't I'm not going to be showing my API
keys in the logs and everything. And
then very similarly,
Kubernetes has Kubernetes secrets and
same thing, instead of just a straight
env var, you have a
secret
a secret ref
to an env var.
And this is my reminder to show you how
I install my containers at the end. I
have a really cool tool. I built it just
for me with everything that I need to
run containers. I'm not pushing it on
anyone, but it's in GitHub and at the
end I can
let you know where that is. You can try
it if you want.
So, when I
So,
thank
I think we're heading to a world where
these agents, these AI workloads,
whatever,
are going to be running everywhere. I
hope we all can see that. And so,
imagine my vision is for uh
everybody's OpenClaws to be
uh running everywhere and communicating
with each other. And uh when and
especially in for like business use
cases, real real things, not astrology
and and Bruins.
Uh that opens up
the need
that
the same need to run any application uh
in that way is
security and
and how to do it at scale.
And that's what Kubernetes gives you.
And you can
What I always do is develop something
locally and then lift it to Kubernetes.
And so, the same story holds for AI
workloads or OpenClaw.
And I was at PyTorch Con yesterday and
um
my friend from Nvidia said I could share
this. They are running
their model evals
with OpenClaw. They have about 10
engineers. They each have their
OpenClaws running in Kubernetes and uh
periodically just checking in with the
model evals.
And it works so well for them. He said
it was like, you know, doing the job of
six engineers
uh
in with with himself. Now,
let's think let's just talk about that
for a second. We're not all losing our
jobs, people. Like that's not happening.
What's What that is enabling for his
team is they get to do fun stuff,
interesting stuff. They get to do
creative things. And this is what AI is
giving me and my team is we can focus on
those like outside the box crazy things
and you don't have to do the tedious
code anymore. Like I haven't written
code in in a few months. And this this
did just happen like
probably less than 6 months ago. I was
using AI I was like,
"You know what? This is way better than
me at writing code." And there's
I like
Yeah. And I I announced that to my team.
We had an org meeting and I'm like,
"Guys, if you're not using AI for
everything, like you're missing out.
This is 1,000 times better than me at
writing code." And some of the top
engineers at Red Hat like definitely
raised eyebrows and I could tell from
their comments after that they were
like, "No way." I'm like, "Yeah." Uh and
so So yes, it's it's
it's enabling us to just dream bigger
and
uh
This is my reminder to show you the
Kubernetes side of my installer later.
And um yeah, so backup and recovery is a
nice clean story when you run in
containers to the state is the same
volumes. Another nice thing about Docker
and Podman is there are volumes. And so
all of my runtime state lives in a nice
contained Podman volume.
And of course Kubernetes has PVCs.
That's kind of what I just talked about.
And so this this would be my vision of
workplace setup for Open Claw where you
maybe have your nice curated baseline
Open Claw that as a new hire you you
just you get your your base. And what
does that have in it? It has your list
of company approved MCP servers,
your authentication that is approved
through your company. It has all of your
these skills that are very specific to
your team,
maybe access to your Google Drive. Like
all these things uh
that you use every day at work.
You can take that and just fan it out
across your whole team.
And then
And then you can personalize it as as
the individual. And that's what
this what this setup allows.
The alternative would be you're a new
hire and you sit next to somebody or get
somebody's
repo and kind of put it all together
yourself. Um
And so yeah, team standards
portable environments
reproducible onboarding. That's my
vision for like Open Claw in the
workplace in the future.
Uh I actually just recently created my
forever claw. It it was like a month of
me
helping out with with Open Claw and
feeling like I don't even run a real
Open Claw myself. I just constantly
throughout the day I'm spinning it up,
spinning it down, testing it, building
it. Every hour there's like 100 new
commits. So I'm constantly pulling from
main. I was at PyTorchCon yesterday and
hadn't pulled from main for a couple of
days. Uh and and there were times when I
did it was like 10,000 commits. No joke,
it was crazy. I'm like, "I don't know
what you guys are doing. Slow down."
Uh not really, we don't want to slow
down. So yes,
uh
that's that's the story.
And I've got four more minutes. I am
psyched cuz I can now
switch over here.
So in order to run this local installer
here
which I think I have here.
Yeah.
It's just a NPM run dev. Now
The one thing I don't like about this is
when I'm on my Mac
I can't run this in a container.
Uh I I think I can. I just haven't taken
the time to figure out how to spawn a
container from a container. You can do
that if you're on Linux cuz Linux is
awesome. But on your Mac, that's not
possible because if you don't know,
whenever you're running a container on
your Mac, you're running in a virtual
machine. Same with Docker. Containers
only run on Linux. So when you're
running a container on your Mac, you are
always running in a virtual machine.
Docker sets up one and so does Mac. So
it gets a little tricky when you want to
take a container and spawn another
container from it. But anyways, here we
go.
So if I wanted to run a local instance
and I have a couple running now. Just
you know, you never know the demo gods
what they're up to. So I'm just in case
it doesn't work. I'm going to I'm going
to um
spin up Joe.
All I all I do to set up
my pod is I just give it a name.
And then all of these options very
opinionated cuz I I'm telling you this
is exactly what I need. So if it's if
you like it, use it. If you want to
change it, then submit a PR. Cool. Now
uh the port is usually 89. That's the
default. But since this is my second one
that I'm running on my machine, I had to
I'm just bumping it to 99.
These Podman secret mappings I want to
show you here.
So you can see I have these set up
already. They're just on my system.
They're like envars, but they're not
envars cuz they're contained.
Um these are my API keys.
And what happens with this installer
is it takes If you're on Docker, this
should work with Docker. It's got Podman
written all over it, but I've designed
it to work with Docker, too. So
um if you're on Docker, it takes the
envars. So you want to export those as
envars and um makes them Open Claw
secret refs.
Very cool feature of Open Claw.
Definitely enable that. For every
current credential, create a secret ref.
It creates that separation of uh running
your secret within Open Claw or kind of
just a pointer to it. It's it's it's
it's the way to go.
And then uh your providers. So I'm going
to start with Open Router cuz I have
been playing with Gemma.
And she's Gemma's great.
And then as a fallback I'll use
Anthropic. Sure, why not?
But you Oh, here's here's some other
choices, though.
You can you can have your local endpoint
if you're running your own.
You could just
add that, too.
And then because I do observability at
work
uh I was like, "I'm going to give the
option to set up an Open Telemetry
collector with Jaeger."
And it works and it's awesome, but I'm
not going to test it. So let's not tax
my system.
Another feature
How much time? Oh, I got to hurry.
Another feature is SSH sandbox here
we'll deploy.
The SSH sandbox in Open Claw is super
cool. You give it SSH keys and known
hosts to
to wherever you want and it it runs all
of its commands in that workspace. It's
really cool. So look, I just spun up a
Podman container. And if I go over to
the instances
I have now have Joe.
And there's logs
for Joe, the gateway logs.
Um the command I want to show you the
command. Don't want to forget that.
So here is the Podman command. If you
were running Docker, it would be a
Docker command. Have I tested with this
with Docker? No.
Uh I have a friend who works at Docker.
He's awesome. He told me he would try
this out and make it make sure it works
with Docker, too. Um he also created
this very cool project called Infer
RS which takes
uh Gemma and runs it really really
really fast and uses Turbo Quant.
Uh so anyways, that's um Eric.
So that that's my Podman command and
uh
Here he is. Joe.
And if I just do like models
I'll do status.
So
people say it's hard to spin up Open
Claw. It took 2 seconds and I was
babbling through the whole way. It could
have taken 1 second.
Uh so I can say hey
um
And the cool thing is I don't have time
to show you because I talk too much, but
the agents are all set up. I've got Joe.
Oh, that not that one. Hold on. I got to
go over to Larry.
Larry I started with a um
with an MCP server and a sub-agent. Um,
all through that form.
So,
uh, let me go back to Joe.
I wanted to show you how easy it is just
to switch models in case you didn't
know.
I'm not sure if
the GPT 5, hopefully it knows it's just
GPT 5.4.
No, I I didn't No. No. No. We got to go
over to Larry.
Cuz I didn't set up
I didn't set up the extra model with
with Joe.
There we go.
Anyways, um,
I didn't have enough time to go through
everything I wanted to go through, but
the,
uh,
Cool.
The other thing is Kubernetes. And you
can do the same thing with Kubernetes
just as easy.
It just, uh, it it's connected right now
to my kind cluster.
And if I go over, I can access my
Kubernetes claw very easily as well.
Um,
There's Carl. He's running in
Kubernetes. And I can access one in
OpenShift. There's, uh, it switches over
to OpenShift if you're connected to
OpenShift. So, yeah. Uh, run Anyone
going to run Open Claw container? No?
Try it. Yes.
Awesome. Okay, cool.
Uh, thank you very much. Uh,
is someone on after me? You're waiting?
Okay, bye.
>> [laughter]
[applause]
[music]